- [Voiceover] Hair insecurity is something
that a lot of men feel and
almost none talk about.
- 30% of men suffer from
hair loss by the age of 30.
That's a lot of guys.
- [Voiceover] The people I hang
out with, nobody talks about hair.
- [Voiceover] They're
uncomfortable with the idea of
balding because they expect
that I'm uncomfortable with it.
- They feel like there's no options at all
- They're like whatever, it happens,
I'm gonna bald, look at my dad.
- [Voiceover] It was just
weighting on my self confidence.
- I think that we need to down
to the root of this problem.
- I noticed hair loss
for me when I was 27.
- [Voiceover] My wife told me I have a
bald spot in the back.
- When did she tell you,
you have a bald spot?
- She just told me this last night.
- To think it's the first time
this is initially addressed,
like this is something that is real.
I was coming to this video.
- Self analysis.
Don't be scared to take a look at it.
- I ignored it for a long time.
So, I showed you photos of me in college
and you're like oh yeah I
can see it started there
and I'm like what, no it didn't.
- The earlier you discover
it, the better chance
you have of preventing it.
What's your perception of
hair loss and why it happens?
- They say it might happen
from the mothers' father side.
- False, genetics on both sides.
So, you're literally rolling the dice.
Do your proper research.
Look at your parents,
look at your grandparents.
Have you ever done research?
- I don't think that I have.
- Why is that?
- It's because of that inedibility,
nothing that I do is going to stop it.
- Men suffer from something
called Androgenetic Alopecia.
Men usually bald on top
of their crown area,
in the frontal lobe to the back.
It's kind of like that Friar Tuck look.
- What you tell me is that
it's testosterone that's
blocking the area.
- [David] Yes.
So, I'm too much of a man,
that's the problem here.
- Oh God, here we go.
It's DHT that causes it,
which is a type of hormonal testosterone.
It's hair miniaturization that
basically closes the follicle.
- I've just kind of given up.
- We're here today to discover
what we can do for you.
- I'd love that.
- [David] Self analysis will
lead in to hair scriptions.
- We have a mutual friend
and you do his hair.
His hair is fantastic
and I'm like I what that.
I'm going to corner you and I
am going to get your secrets.
- As far as hair scription is concerned,
you're saying like how easy it is.
- I'm happy applying a cream
to my head twice a day.
I have a pill that supports
strong hair growth.
Something that adds two
minutes to my morning routine.
- My hairline wasn't
magically reappearing,
but it was slowing down the process.
- A huge avenue that people
like to explore besides surgery,
is a laser comb.
- Laser comb?
- Right, the density
in their hair is a lot
more than what we started with.
- Propecia, I tried it.
It was fine in the
beginning, but I noticed
my sex drive and my energy
were lower than normal.
- You were really great at
making sure I understood
how and why I style my hair a certain way.
- [David] There's an old myth
of lets just keep growing
your hair out and then we will
cover the areas of concern.
- Sort of trying to press it
into place as much as possible.
- You don't see the spots
or the receding parts.
- [David] Walk me through
your hair routine.
- It's an old ancient
technique of water and a comb.
- I feel that I need to find
a style that works with it
because it's thinning.
- I think that you can
definitely rock different looks.
- Within seconds, your whole entire begin
kind of just changed and shifted.
- I looked good.
- When people look at you,
you're look straight onto them.
Anything that's shorter tighter here,
will focus on their jawline,
will focus on their eyes
so that it eliminates the
focus on any hair loss.
We are going to try anything
possible besides surgery.
- [Voiceover] I had a couple friends that
have done hair restoration.
- [Voiceover] There's only a
handful of people that actually
know that I've gotten surgery.
- Wait, so today...
- Yeah, I'm not embarrassed of it,
I was able to find something
that really fit my budget,
and did what I want.
They took the hair follicles
from the back of my head
and placed them at the front.
After that, eight, nine months,
you start getting your hair growing back.
I fixed what the issue was
and now I'm preventing.
Some guys don't care.
But, if they care, you should ideally
have a stylist that you trust.
- I think it's important for guys to
not only have a open
conversation with each other
and be honest each other,
and be hey, I'm noticing
something, maybe you should
check it out or go see a stylist,
because they really
know what they're doing.
- As where sort of talking
about it and embracing it,
we can share the tips we
are sharing right now.
Which I would never
have ever found without
just having a conversation.
So, this is positive
hair, positive person,
- [David] Yes.
love it.
- I looked at it as a
haircut I wish I always had.
- [David] You look 10 years younger.
- Wow, hey.
- [Voiceover] Hey, wow!
- What do you think?
- [Voiceover] Your head is a square.
Wow!
- Thank you so much, I
really appreciate it.
- There's no shame in going
bald and if you are that's fine.
- Yeah.
- I think it's also important
to know there are things
you can do about it and that if it's
something that make you
fell better, take action.